Krebse, Muscheln und Seesterne –
insgesamt rund zehntausend Tier-
und Pflanzenarten
leben hier im Rhythmus der Gezeiten.
Bei Wattführungen könnt ihr diesen
Lebensraum erforschen.
Eine faszinierende Welt, die seit 2009
zum UNESCO-Weltnaturerbe gehört.
Auch Dünen, Salzwiesen und Sandbänke
gehören zur Schutzzone.
Das Highlight aber ist ein Besuch
bei den Seehunden,
den beliebtesten Bewohnern des Watts.
Ausflugsboote bringen euch ganz nah ran
an die scheuen Tiere.
Das solltet ihr nicht verpassen.
Um diese Natur in ihrer Vielfalt
zu erhalten,
wurden schon vor mehr als 30 Jahren
große Teile Norderneys zum
Nationalpark erklärt.
Die Insulaner waren erst einmal
nicht so begeistert.
Das hat auch ’ne ganze Zeit gedauert.
Da war Misstrauen sicherlich
auf beiden Seiten:
Die wollen nur ihren Tourismus,
die wollen nur ihren Naturschutz.
Aber das hat sich dann doch anschließend
sehr schnell erledigt.
Mittlerweile ist das Wattenmeer längst
Teil des touristischen Konzepts.
Ranger des Nationalparks machen Besucher
mit den Wattbewohnern bekannt –
zum Beispiel dem Strandfloh.
Das ist das Chamäleon der Nordsee.
Die leben auf dem Meeresboden,
graben sich ein
und können sich über ihre Pigmente,
also diese Punkte,
ein bisschen dunkler färben.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal auf dem Watt
und ziemlich sprachlos,
was man da alles finden kann.
Es ist klasse.
Traumhaft irgendwo.
Wir kommen auf jeden Fall wieder.
Ich find’s auch lustig, durch den Schlick
zu laufen und dieses leckere –
wie heißt es – Salzgras zu essen.
Ist sehr toll und spannend.
Und plötzlich sehen die Besucher nicht nur
Schlick und Schlamm,
sondern erkennen Zusammenhänge.
Das ist genau das,
was die Ranger erreichen wollen.
Hier muss man erst sehr genau hingucken,
man muss sehr fein da rangehen,
um zu erkennen,
was für eine Vielfalt hier herrscht.
Sie ist nicht so offensichtlich
und nicht so pompös wie in den Tropen,
aber sie kann,
wenn man genauer hinguckt,
genauso begeistern und ist genauso schön.
Wenn alles gut läuft, sind die Gäste
bei ihrer Abreise achtsamer
und haben mehr Respekt
für die Landschaft,
in der sie Urlaub machen.